My husband's been craving barbecue chicken pizza
and he wanted to order for dinner tonight,
so I decided to get a head start
and just make it myself.
I never thought I'd be making barbecue chicken pizza
as a European,
but here we are.
I started by making my dough
and letting that rise for about two hours,
and in the meantime,
I made my barbecue sauce by combining some ketchup,
red wine vinegar,
garlic, some other condiments,
and letting that simmer.
Once it's thickened,
I let it cool and started on making my cheese.
Made a simple mozzarella cheese by combining some milk
with some renet and some citric acid,
letting that sit,
slicing up my curds in a grid pattern,
and then returning that to the stove,
and I let it drain
and stretched it out to form my little cheese balls.
Once my dough has doubled in size,
I flour down my work surface
and make sure to coat it in all that flour
because it is really sticky.
Divided into four pieces,
form those into little balls
and let those rest for another 30 minutes.
Cover them with a kitchen towel
to prevent them from drying out,
and then move on to making my shredded chicken.
Can season it however you like.
Just make sure your pan is really hot
to get a good sear on it,
and let that fry
and slice up my red onion in the meantime.
Once my chicken was done and Rested,
I shredded it up and set that aside.
I like prepping all my ingredients,
so I sliced up my mozzarella
and also decided to add some banana peppers. This point,
I formed my dough into little circles,
spread some of that barbecue sauce on there.
Then I went in with some chicken peppers, some onion,
my mozzarella,
and slid that onto my pizza stone.
Let that bake for about five to six minutes,
topped it with cilantro,
some more barbecue sauce,
and dinner was done.